- [Kelly Clarkson] You're about to be a
part of a groundbreaking, like
new Broadway show, right?
I'm so excited about this.
- [Kandi Burruss] Yessss, I'm so excited!
- That's a lot of work!
- Yes! So, the show is called,
Thoughts of a Colored Man.
- Yeah.
- And it's a groundbreaking
show because this is the first
time ever that seven black
men, an all black cast,
starring on Broadway with a director who,
black director, black writer.
- Yeah, African-American
everything, I love that.
- Black producer,
African-American everything!
The thing about it is, you
know, for so, so many years,
you know,
we didn't see enough diversity
on Broadway and now we're
coming back and we bring in
such spice to diversity when
Broadway is coming back.
- Yeah.
- It's an amazing show
mixing, spoken word with,
it's just amazing.
You just have to see it to see
black men in that light where
they're bringing such greatness
to the theater and I'm
excited about it.
- Yeah, and they're all
different, you said there's seven
different lives, right?
- Yes, well, they're different,
bringing different emotions.
- Ooh!
- So we'll see them in a way
that you've never seen before,
starring some amazing actors.
I'm a producer on the show.
A lot of people think
that I'm in the show,
I'm a producer on the show.
And so for me to be behind the scenes,
working on a show like this
on Broadway in this way,
when this is the first time
Broadway has ever shut down for
as long as it did.
- Yeah.
- So to be able to come back and come in,
and I actually be a part
of a show that's coming,
bringing Broadway back to life.
- Yeah.
- I'm just so excited.
I really hope that everybody
chooses to come and hang out
with us and see the show.
It's going to be amazing
- I think everyone.
- We start in October.
- Everyone's dying to come
back and see the show.
I literally have already been
to like two, like concert.
I'm like, and I'm doing it
safely, but I'm just like,
I need a life.
Like we want our lives up,
we want to be entertained.
And especially coming to New York.
- Listen, New York is
the place for theater.
- For the arts, yeah.
- And musicals, and arts, and you know,
it was kinda sad to see,
you know, all the shows have
to shut down for so long.
- Yeah.
- So I'm just so happy that
we're able to bring life back to
the theater world again.
- It's kinda cool too though,
because then it reminds
us how great we had it.
We didn't even know how lucky
we were to see so many shows,
whatever you want to do
at the same, you know,
at the tip of your fingers,
like it's always all here,
and then it all went away and
you were like, wait a minute.
Like we needed that.
- Yes!
- We didn't realize how,
especially a city like this.
I'm so stoked for you.
Congratulations, That's so cool.
- Thank you!
- Yeah, It's so, so, so cool.
So the last time you
were here, we were about,
you were about to welcome a
new daughter. So how is she.
- Blaze?
- Yeah. Which is such a great name,
but you're kind of setting
yourself up for like a
firecracker.
- She's a firecracker!
(both laughing)
- Her name represents her well.
- I know, I was like. (laughs)
- Listen, she is such a
sweetheart, but at the same time,
she's so feisty.
- Mine is too.
- And so funny, like with
Blaze, okay, she makes
these faces, right?
- Yeah.
- Like me, I make, everybody knows
- Expressive, yep.
- She's very expressive, but you know,
I had to do this thing with
her because she just does what
she wants to do.
And so I had to get to get in
her face and say stop it right
now. So now what she does
to me is when she's mad,
she's like.
- Oh my gosh. And so young
and doing that already.
- Yes! Frowning up at me, and telling me.
- Good luck. (claps)
So here's the face I want
to talk about though.
Have you ever felt yourself
having your mom's face?
Like you can feel that you
have your mom's face with your
child when you're like angry
or something. I'm like,
oh my God, that was my mom.
- Well, my mom, definitely
makes faces. So I think it's,
it's a generational
thing, we can't help it.
- Yeah, yeah, we're all expressive.